the jurogan experience but again that
goes back to like
you have an excuse all the time to do
the wrong thing you have an excuse all
the time to go back to the familiar you
have an excuse all the time why to say
the whole world is against you and be
right but so what now what now what are
you going to do about it how happy do
you want to be your life will rise to
the level you settle for
and just to keep pushing
what did you do how did you get out of
it like how did you what was the first
job that you got
when i was homeless yeah
[Music]
uh i started because i grew up singing i
was like maybe i could get a gig
somewhere and start singing because i
made money singing you know like for my
whole life since i was little like 100
bucks 200 bucks but whatever so i'd go
around the coffee shops um in the area
but san diego started to be a hotbed for
signing activity you know grunge there
was like kind of a grunge scene in san
diego
and so i'd go in there and they they
charged you to sing there
i was like this is not ideal like they
wanted me to pay them two hundred
dollars i was like yeah i was like this
is the one gig yeah and it was the idea
that you would sell tickets they thought
it was no they thought it was like a
signing you would get signed oh god you
know what i mean because it became like
so many record labels i guess were
coming down at the time
i remember this one lady like my friend
let me sit in on his gig
so i go sing with them i'm starting to
write my own songs oh i forgot to tell
you how i started writing songs back at
school but i'll tell you later
i remember that
so i started writing songs um and
singing my own stuff i get on my
friend's gig he's packed the place out i
don't clearly but he has it crowded
there's like a door charge
so i go to settle out while he's taking
his gear down and this woman coffee shop
owner was like you guys don't get the
door money and i was like
what are you talking about like he
brought all these people in she's like
no she goes you get the tip jar
and i was like
oh
i was like you know what then why don't
we get all your coffee and food money
you could just give us that instead
and she was like you don't get the food
beverage money you get the tip jar and i
was so upset i needed the money so badly
like i didn't have food you know like i
was
i was really wanting some money from
that gig and i remember i put my little
finger in her face and i was like i am
cursing you
whoa you are i know it sounds so heavy
i was like you are stealing from the
people that are giving you a living
you're stealing from this guy and i was
like you are you will go out of business
i was like nobody can stay in business
doing this to humans i was so upset at
her and i
did he have a understanding with her or
was he just getting wrong i didn't care
he just didn't care i was [ __ ] hippie
blown away i was like
he was just wanted to be easy going and
didn't want to make her mad and wanted
to get another gig there and i was just
so upset and so
i found this place i liked this little
when i was living in my car there was a
little tree that was flowering tree and
i like to park next to it so like that
was my home
and i noticed there was this coffee shop
right there that was going out of
business and it was really off the
beaten path
and so i went in there and i talked to
the lady who owned it her name was nancy
and i was like do you think you could
stay open for two more months
and she's like why i'm like if i bring
people in
can i keep the door money you can keep
all the coffee and food
and like we'll try and make it together
and she said yes and so i started going
down on like the beach front in san
diego and i'd sing like street sing
and i'd tell people i'm singing at the
interchange coffee shop on thursday
night at six o'clock and
two people came like it was two surfers
that thought i was hot i think
and i did a five-hour show because bar
singing you do five-hour shows and i
just thought i had to do a five-hour
show so i started writing a ton of
material plus i was using writing not to
steal and i was a prolific thief so i
had to become a prolific writer
and so i did this five hour show to
these two guys i'm bleeding my heart out
because i was so lonely and i realized i
never tell the truth like nobody knows
the truth
i'm scared to death i'm not a great
person i'm stealing
and i'm lonely and i was like maybe if i
tell the truth i won't feel so lonely so
i made a promise that i would write
really honest songs so these poor two
servers were subjected to five hours
of like
bleeding out my like vocal cords
it was amazing i made ten dollars
and uh the next night and i would go
sing all throughout town street corner
and say hey thursday night they knew
where to see me and it just grew it went
from two people to four people to eight
people
to 40 to 80 to capacity to people
standing outside watching me sing
through the window and i got discovered
wow yeah
it was nuts
wow
yeah
that's a great story
wow what was that like
what was it was it feeling like when it
was at capacity and you recognize that
these people were
that something was changing in your life
these people are coming out to see you
perform
the coolest thing and why i'm smiling is
because i was changing it moves me to
tears right now
even before the people came i felt the
momentum shifting you know i just felt
i was getting better i was getting
healthier i was getting happier my panic
attacks like i found out how not to have
them
like it just made me feel good and then
when these people came
i just bore my soul and i just didn't
pull a punch and they
they liked me and i know that sounds
superficial but it wasn't because it was
so authentically me i wasn't pretending
to be better or more talented
it was so raw
and people would cry and i would cry
and it was just such a real connection
like for the first time in my life i had
a real meaningful human connection and
it wasn't scary it
felt good
and they would give me books to read and
they would give me food
and i didn't think it would lead to a
record deal it just felt like being fed
for the first time in your life you know
not hiding and not being fake and just
being really authentic so it felt really
good
and then when more people came it just
took on a momentum that was like holy
[ __ ] how much time
is passed from the two people to people
standing outside
you know i don't know but six months
maybe
ish something like that
that's a lot of change in six months
yeah maybe a little more eight months
but couldn't have been more than that
because i don't think i was homeless
more than a year what was that that
change had to feel crazy it was wild
it was cool and you know from like being
on stage but like i wouldn't make a set
list and i would just feel the audience
and like i talked i did a lot of i tell
a lot of stories and like kind of like
stand up i would just tell like just
stories and
jokes and just shoot [ __ ] with people in
the audience and they were just these
really live electric like kind of wild
shows
and make them dead quiet and
i would just take little breaks so
people could use the bathroom and
and when people started standing outside
and they couldn't hear but they were
just watching me through the window and
the look on their face like to this day
it like gives me chills like they looked
at me with like a certain look and it
was like holy [ __ ] like this is
different
and they would stand out in the rain
like we put little speakers out there so
they could hear and people would stand
in the rain and just listen to me
singing through the window with little
speakers and it was just like it was
very humbling like very very humbling
wow yeah
so then what happens how do you get
discovered
there was a radio dj programmer excuse
me he ran 91x which is a really big
radio station in the country they might
have been number two in the country at
the time heavy alternative station
somebody told him about this girl
singing in a coffee shop and that he
should come
and he came in i could recognize new
faces when they come in because it was
this wasn't a big place by the way i
mean this might have been 70 people that
could fit inside that's a tiny costume
so you had developed a crowd like
you were accustomed to seeing familiar
faces yeah i was a loyal
die hard
die hard fan base like tiny don't get me
wrong
but i knew them you know what i mean it
was it was like a little family in a way
and so this guy came in he had a goatee
his final shirt on he looked kind of
hard and he was sitting in the back and
i remember singing the song a thousand
miles away and he was just weeping like
quietly but just tears were streaming
down his face
and he came up to me afterwards he's
like hey i'm at the radio station and
like why don't you come in like sing a
song one night or something and i was
like okay
so i go in there
i'm still living in oh i got another car
so i had a car to live in um i'd saved
up enough door money to buy a car
cheap car like a couple hundred dollar
car
um so i get down to the radio station
and i sing a song for him and we talk a
little bit and um
i guess he went ahead him and this guy
named lou niles put it uh
on the radio and they got requested um
by fans so it's back when you could
still request songs and they'd listen to
it
and it got somehow into the top
20
you know of this station
which is a big deal like top 20 on that
station was like you know labels pay a
lot of money to promote their artist to
try and get them into the top 20 and
this was like an acoustic guitar demo
in the middle of like all this grunge
music and so record labels were like
how that what is this song that's
showing up on this playlist and they
would call him and he's like it's this
chick down at this coffee shop and so
all of a sudden there would be like
these limousines pulling up
and they would give sweet little nancy
you know that was just she was having a
banging business now which felt so good
and they would be like she'd be like
jewel sony records is here tonight
all right i was so passe about the whole
thing it was very funny
um and then they'd take me out to tacos
and
talk to me about record deals and and
then there was a bidding war it was
every label came down every label
they'd flown from new york they'd bring
in bigger executives then they'd fly in
they'd come again they'd you know all
these limousines showing up
and i would start to get flown around to
talk to different record labels
and
how does this process take
i don't know
i am i'm kind of bad with time that way
i don't know a couple months something
like that and you don't have a manager
you don't have anybody speaking for you
no but i went to the library and i found
this book called
[Laughter]
how to manage yourself by for dummies
[Laughter]
it was don passenheim i think called
everything you need to know about the
music business oh boy and that sounded
good so i read it and i just learned
about mechanicals and royalties and
back-ends and advances oh so you did
your homework i did my homework and
there ended up being a huge bidding war
over me um all the labels just started
like competing by this time i kind of
found like a de facto manager
um
i maybe got a lawyer here at some point
you know and this might now have taken
more time
but i realized because of reading that
book that an advance is a loan you don't
get to keep the money
you pay it back through record sales
and so i did the math to see how many
records i'd have to sell to pay back a
million dollars and it was a lot of
records
and so it was like having a bounty on my
head as an artist
i almost didn't sign my record deal
because i had just figured out how to be
happy like genuinely i was really
starting to figure it out and i knew it
like inside myself i was doing so much
better
and
god forbid you take somebody with my
emotional background
and they ever get famous i'm the recipe
for every movie you've seen about every
musician like right
and again i didn't want to be a
statistic and i fought so hard for my
happiness up to this point that i was
like i don't think i could trust myself
to have a record deal
and figure out how to do that career
without self-imploding so i almost
didn't sign it
i remember being on the beach one day
and i was like
i wanted to do it but i was terrified of
doing it so i made myself a promise that
my number one job would still be to
figure out how to be happy and my number
two job would be to be a musician
and then under the musician category
that i wanted to be an artist more than
i wanted to be famous
and so knowing those was like having my
north star and i felt like i could
navigate and make decisions based on
those things
and so i went ahead and signed the
record deal i turned down the advance i
turned down a million dollar bonus holy
[ __ ] as a homeless kid oh my god
oh my god that is so crazy
and i took the biggest do that that's i
would have
taken that money for sure a hundred
percent i've been like i'll figure it
out in the future
taking this money i'm getting a [ __ ]
fat apartment overlooking the water
this is not what i did as a homeless kid
you'd pass on a million bucks i did wow
but
i took the biggest back end anybody had
ever been awarded
and so if i sold records i was going to
make a [ __ ] ton
so because like under the artist
category i wanted to be an artist more
than i wanted to be famous and it meant
i had to put myself in an environment
and in a position to win as a
singer-songwriter and as a folk singer
no less at the height of grunge
the odds of that working i knew were
really slim and i felt like the bidding
war over me was just much more of like a
dick contest between all the labels i
didn't think it necessarily had to do
with my talent i thought i was talented
but i thought the odds were still really
really against me
and i had to put myself in a position to
be able to
weather
the fact that my first album may not be
successful
but if you have a million dollar signing
bonus you have to have your first let
record be successful or else you'll get
dropped because you cost so much the
label
and so i was just doing it to put myself
in a position to make my art first and
to not leverage my art unduly you know
it's like saying you have to grow a pear
but you don't even have a tree yet
like i had to grow a tree like the pear
was a long way away
and so i just tried to look at it kind
of agriculturally or in a natural system
of like i have to grow i have to plant a
seed i have to like grow a tree you know
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify